[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions ou de
bus symbolisme en termes de technique ce
sera absolument parfait et ils veulent
une fanfare pas possible pour la coupe
du monde 2022 qui est la priorité de
l'émirat pourquoi le qatar utilise le
sport le foot plus particulièrement
comme outil de soft power ici vous
regarde en termes d'argent le faut ce
qu'on dit c'est de l'argent tu sais
c'est que dalle en fait c'est peanuts
donc si vous voulez aujourd'hui être
affiché à travers tous les continents
avoir une image et en plus un an de la
coupe du monde et ses rêvés pour le
qatar parce qu'on va reparler d'eux et
encore pour des raisons d'ailleurs
plutôt mélioratif plutôt bien
[Musique]
allez les législatives ont débuté en
russie un long scrutin deux trois jours
jusqu'à dimanche au terme de cette
journée on reconnaîtra les premiers
résultats il s'agit pour les électeurs
de renouveler la composition de la douma
la chambre basse du parlement
[Musique]
les enjeux lourds est rase il apprend à
l'instant
[Musique]
le cap des 50 millions de primo
vaccinées atteint d'une annonce des
manuels macron dans une vidéo postée sur
les réseaux sociaux et cela sur fond de
polémique autour de l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants la fête en
vigueur depuis mercredi non sans
contestation le hic
en guadeloupe impossible d'appliquer la
mesure près de 75 % du personnel le chu
avait pas vaccinés explications à suivre
dans cette édition
les chefs d'état doivent ouest africain
tape du poing sur la table il demande
des élections en guinée d'ici six mois
elles ont pris les sanctions aussi
contre les putschistes qui ont fait
tomber alpha condé le 5 septembre une
délégation de la communauté économique
des états d'afrique de l'ouest la cedeao
et sur place en ce moment
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur un rt france on commence
avec les législatives en russie elles
ont débuté aujourd'hui et vont se
dérouler tout le week end jusqu'à
dimanche inclus crise sanitaire oblige
il s'agit de scrutin important pour
renouveler la douma 450 sièges de la
chambre basse du parlement russe
beaucoup d'enjeux pour ces élections
comme nous l'expliquent notre
correspondant à moscou en pointe claire
au point depuis ce vendredi matin les
citoyens russes sont appelés à
renouveler les 450 sièges de la douma la
chambre basse du parlement afin d'éviter
les files d'attenté les attroupements le
vote se déroule sur trois jours les
électeurs peuvent se rendre dans leur
bureau de vote habituel ou bien voter en
ligne comme l'ont d'ores et déjà fait le
premier ministre mais aussi le président
qui en a profité pour passer un message
à ses concitoyens
balla gaye 2 si vous ne viviez en ligne
le scrutin pour la huitième législature
de la douma a débuté aujourd'hui dans
notre pays il durera trois jours nous
voyons
aucun cas inutile comme vous le voyez
sur fond de restrictions sanitaires de
quarantaine j'ai rempli mon devoir en
ligne au format électronique hipay enfin
mathias reymond ce système de vote c'est
utilisé partout dans le monde il a déjà
été utilisé à moscou
maintenant les citoyens de cette entité
de la fédération de russie c'est peuvent
bénéficier de ce service
dans l'ensemble je compte sur votre
participation active
le système de vote en ligne mise en
place pour cette élection aurait subi
des attaques informatiques en provenance
des états unis d'ukraine ou encore
d'allemagne selon le ministère russe du
développement numérique cette intrusion
aurait causé quelques ralentissements
sans toutefois en affecter les résultats
toujours d'après la même source ce
vendredi en fin d'après-midi un million
de citoyens avaient d'ores et déjà pu
voter en ligne enfin sont trois bureaux
de vote temporaires ont été installés à
travers le pays dans des hôpitaux qui
accueillent des patients atteints du
cobp et 19 pour que eux aussi puissent
voter
la chambre basse du parlement qui
devrait tourner une page de son histoire
et en ouvrir une nouvelle avec en
principe plus de responsabilités plus de
devoirs et plus de pouvoir tout cela
dans le cadre d'une réforme
constitutionnelle
écoutez l'analyse de pierre laurin et
auteur de nombreux ouvrages sur la
russie les pays de l'ex-union soviétique
maintenant on passe dans un système que
l'on peut qualifier de semis par le
menton c'est à dire que
le parlement la chambre basse en tout
cas la douma va choisir le premier
ministre en fonction des rapports de
force à l'intérieur du
du parlement il est très clair que là
étant donné que le parti présidentiel
russie unie va remporter
vraisemblablement les élections d'une
manière relativement large moins large
que la dernière fois mais
confortable que le parti présidentiel
aura la majorité absolue mais peut-être
pas la majorité
qualifiée pour changer la constitution
ce qu'elle avait jusqu'à présent donc le
premier ministre viendra de cette
formation mais il sera chargé de gérer
lui même enfin avec le gouvernement le
dossier les dossiers économiques et
sociaux du pays espérait pour le 31 août
feu de cap il arrive avec un peu de
retard le seuil des 50 millions de primo
vacciner contre le coc vie de 19 en
france a été franchie une annonce à des
manuels macron aujourd'hui à ce qu'il
représente les trois quarts de la
population française on signale que la
campagne de vaccination tourne au
ralenti et que les indicateurs
épidémique bête aussi ce qui pousse
l'exécutif à réfléchir à un possible
allègement des restrictions même si au
ministère de la santé on joue la carte
de la prudence dix-huit jours de retard
donc pour ce cap des 50 millions de
primo vacciner mais un objectif atteint
avec l'instauration
dupas sanitaires et l'obligation
vaccinale pour les soignants deux
mesures en tout cas très contestées dans
la rue est la dernière elle est entrée
en vigueur mercredi en métropole mais
pas en outre-mer qui disposent d'un
délai supplémentaire et pour cause en
guadeloupe a par exemple plus de 70% des
soignants du chu de pointe à pitre n'a
pas encore entamé son parcours vaccinale
elle son directeur général estime ne pas
pouvoir les suspendre comme prévoit la
loi sur l'obligation vaccinale au risque
de mettre en péril le bon fonctionnement
de ses services je prends donc sur moi
cette responsabilité de faire tourner
l'hôpital malgré la loi c'est ce qu'il a
déclaré on va écouter à ce propos
philippe bélair il est secrétaire
général de la cgtg à santés guadeloupe
une liste de la santé à phil
déclarations médiatiques il ya presqu'un
mois où il a bien constaté la situation
que la synergie quitté de caldwell et
qu'il fallait tenir compte de cette
situation
dames de la mesure on serait devant un
problème le problème c'est d'avoir du
personnel
fort que ça nous attendions décret
note ministérielle pour pouvoir modifier
le décret de lille c'est tout
malheureusement ça n'est jamais venu
sauf que la pression est arrivé au
moment même le 15 on m'a même chalet
impérativement
où les autorités avoir tous les éléments
en termes de vaccination ils se sont
retrouvés devant cette réalité c'est
qu'il y a pas seulement au chu il y a
quasiment dans tous les hôpitaux il ya
effectivement un fort taux de personnel
qui
washing à accepter non pas la
vaccination encore une fois mais
le vaccin hib je suis j'aime à souligner
ça c'est qu'en fait je crois que si les
autorités font le choix de vaccins
conventionnel
je ne pense pas que ce père je crois
même je suis persuadé que ce personnel
va se ranger dans les rangs
de galles dans le tyrol autrichien
station de ski huppée est devenu en mars
2020 l'un des principaux lieux de
propagation a décoré d'un virus en
europe de nombreuses familles des
victimes ont porté plainte elle pointe
du doigt la responsabilité et des
autorités locales et notamment leur
réaction trop tardive le procès s'est
ouvert aujourd'hui à vienne allez
précision avec robin pu elle et nicolas
petit
c'est le premier procès d'une longue
série qui s'est ouvert ce vendredi les
juges se penche sur la plainte déposée
par six glynn choc dont le mari est
décédé en avril 2020 le retraité de 72
ans aurait été infecté par le cos vite
19 lors du départ en urgence de tous les
vacanciers de la station de ski 10
gueule après l'annnonce de confinement
localiser le 13 mars 2020 pour l'avocat
de la famille les autorités n'ont pas
pris les mesures de précaution
nécessaires selon un rapport d'experts
dès le 5 mars 2020 l'islande se serait
inquiété du retour de touristes
infectées 120
mm le dimanche 8 mars 2020 le serveur
d'un bar à brécy qui a été testé positif
aux convives 19 ski pas un bar après ce
qui devenu tristement célèbre jeu le
science lors osnt
il a été clairement établi si ce que le
personnel touristique 10 gueule avait
contracté le virus
mais que cette fois encore on a réagi
trop tard ou lâche trop peu trop tard
too late
au total plus de 6000 personnes
originaires de 45 pays affirme qu elles
ou leurs proches ont été contaminées
dont la station huppée dis-je gueule ou
dans ses environs
au moins quinze actions en justice ont
été intentées par des familles de
victimes des parties civiles qui
souhaitent une réaction de l'état
autrichien
je pense que ce que les victimes
attendent le plus c'est que la
république d'autriche prenne enfin ses
responsabilités mais jusqu'à présent il
n'y a aucun signe en ce sens son mari
selon l'association de consommateurs vsv
cette gestion sanitaire approximative
aurait causé la mort de 32 personnes de
leur côté les autorités nient tout
moment comme en estimant avoir agi en
fonction des informations à leur
disposition au moment des faits
là l'idée a rouvert ses frontières avec
la tunisie une décision après deux mois
de fermeture non sans conséquences sur
le pays en proie à cet été à une crise
sanitaire catastrophique à les
précisions à tunis avec notre
correspondant bassam chez 10 c'est une
annonce aux allures de bouffée d'air
frais pour l'économie tunisienne est
celle de la réouverture des frontières
avec le voisin est libyen prévu dès
aujourd'hui elle fait suite à la réunion
de mercredi dernier entre des
délégations sanitaires et sécuritaires
tunisienne et libyenne qui s'était tenue
sur l'île de djerba mais carthage a
prévenu que cette réouverture sera
scruté de très près objectif éviter une
recrudescence des nouveaux cas de
coronavirus le président de la
république aïssa aide a annoncé
l'organisation d'une campagne de
vaccination spécifique au niveau des
postes frontaliers en collaboration avec
les autorités libyennes écouté il est
nécessaire de respecter pleinement le
protocole sanitaire qui pourrait être
révisée au regard de l'évolution de la
situation sanitaire dans les deux pays
tout manquement à ces exigences
pourraient entraîner un réexamen de la
décision de rouvrir les postes
frontaliers le 8 juillet dernier est la
libye avait décidé de fermer ses
frontières avec la tunisie et de
suspendre toutes les liaisons aériennes
en raison d'une quatrième vague
particulièrement meurtrière chez son
voisin peu de temps après tunis décidé
d'en faire de même paralysant une partie
de l'économie nationale premier
partenaire économique des tunisiens dans
le continent tripoli a toujours
représenté une source de revenus
importante pour de nombreux commerçants
et entreprises avant la pandémie les
échanges commerciaux entre les deux pays
représentaient pas moins d'un milliard
250 millions de dollars par an selon le
conseil économique et social contre 300
millions annuels depuis le début de la
crise du coronavirus un manque à gagner
conséquent pour le pays durement touché
par une triple crise économique
politique et sanitaire grâce à la
solidarité internationale la tunisie a
bénéficié de millions de doses en tic au
lead ce qui a permis d'accélérer sa
campagne de vaccination à ce jour plus
de 26 % de la population a complété son
schéma vaccinal et les autorités
tunisiennes espère atteint 50% de
vacciner d'ici le mois de décembre
on va suivre à ce week end a atteint le
8e sommet des pays du sud de l'union
européenne au menu notamment les feux de
forêts dévastateurs de cet été et les
enjeux migratoires l'europe compte
empêcher un flux massif de réfugiés en
provenance d'afghanistan en grèce les
afghans représentent 45 % des arrivées
de migrants sur le sol depuis le mois de
janvier en cause les conflits et les
catastrophes naturelles conclusions d'un
rapport de la banque mondiale publié
cette semaine plusieurs dizaines de
millions de personnes seraient
concernées on voit cela avec estelle
fâche
216 millions c'est le nombre de
personnes dans le monde qui pourrait
devenir des réfugiés climatiques d'ici à
2050 c'est en tout cas ce qu'estime la
banque mondiale l'institution vient de
publier la deuxième édition de son
rapport intitulé groundswell une
nouvelle version beaucoup plus
pessimiste que la précédente concernant
les déplacements de population liés au
changement climatique
en 2018 le rapport estimait que 143
millions de personnes pourraient être
amenés à se déplacer d'ici à 2050 avec
216 millions aujourd'hui c'est désormais
1,5 fois plus ce rapport c'est donc je
cite un appel opportun à une action
urgente les effets du changement
climatique sont de plus en plus visible
nous venons de vivre la décennie la plus
chaude jamais enregistrée et nous
assistons à des phénomènes
météorologiques extrêmes dans le monde
le climat de la terre connaissant des
changements dans chaque région et dans
l'ensemble du système climatique parmi
les régions concernées par ces futurs
déplacements de population l'afrique et
l'asie l'afrique subsaharienne mais
aussi l'afrique du nord où les
perturbations liées à la disponibilité
de l'eau constitue l'un des principaux
moteurs des déplacements de population
en asie du sud selon les modélisations
le bangladesh se révèle particulièrement
concernée avec 13,3 millions de
potentiels futurs déplacés climatiques
en cause la fragilité du pays face à la
montée des eaux la banque mondiale
appelle donc les pays du globe à agir et
ce dès aujourd'hui il est crucial d'agir
maintenant sur le triple plan du climat
du développement et des migrations afin
d'assurer la réalisation des objectifs
de développement durable au cours des
dix prochaines années et parvenir à la
prospérité partagée d'ici au milieu du
siècle présent et au delà
ces prévisions ne sont pas figées pour
la banque mondiale il est encore
possible de réduire le nombre de
réfugiés climatiques à venir notamment
si les pays s'engagent vers des modes de
vie plus respectueux de l'environnement
les migrations climatiques pourraient
être réduites de 80 % ce qui représente
tout de même 44 millions de personnes
d'ici à 2050
les etats-unis ont célébré ce vendredi
le premier anniversaire des accords
d'abraham conclu il ya tout juste un an
par le président donald trump ces
accords ont conduit à une normalisation
des relations entre israël et plusieurs
états arabes pour en parler on va
retrouver à washington notre
correspondant thomas bon escient
thomas bonjour alors pour l'occasion le
chef de la diplomatie américaine a tenu
une réunion virtuelle avec les
représentants des pays concernés
oui cinq représentants ont assisté à
cette réunion virtuelle des
représentants des états unis évidemment
du bahreïn des émirats arabes unis du
maroc et bien sûr d'israël un sommet un
virtuel pour d'une part célébrer le
travail effectué sur la normalisation
des relations entre israël et les pays
arabes et aussi pour lancer un appel à
d'autres pays d'autres représentants
pour qu'ils rejoignent aussi ces accords
d'abraham écouté les explications
d'anthony blinken
nous encourageons davantage de pays à
suivre la voie des émirats de bahreïn et
du maroc nous voulons élargir le cercle
de la diplomatie fascicule c'est dans
l'intérêt des pays de la région et du
monde qu israël doit être traité comme
tous les autres pays la normalisation
prévu à une plus grande stabilité à une
coopération accrue à un développement
mutuel autant de choses dont la région
et le monde ont cruellement besoin en ce
moment à revenir à la conclusion de ces
accords washington avait donné un
certain nombre de garanties aux états
arabes que ce soit à des partenariats
économiques ou dans le cas du maroc en
échange de la normalisation de ses
relations avec israël les etats-unis
reconnaissent la souveraineté du maroc
sur le sahara occidental reste
maintenant donc à convaincre d'autres
pays à rejoindre ces accords en premier
lieu desquels on pense évidemment à
l'arabie saoudite riyad entretient déjà
des relations stratégiques avec israël
mais le pays n'a donc pas signé ces
accords car il existe encore un certain
nombre d'oppositions notamment au sein
de la famille royale saoudienne alors
dans le même temps justement joe biden
il a approuvé un contrat militaire donc
entre les états unis et l'arabie
saoudite la tomate ce qu'on peut dire
que le locataire de la maison blanche
c'est finalement dans la continuité de
la politique étrangère de donald trump
ou il paraît loin le temps de la
campagne présidentielle américaine ou
joe biden promettait de faire payer les
dirigeants saoudiens pour le meurtre du
journaliste kamel jamal khashoggi pardon
le président des états unis semble
finalement avoir privilégié les
relations économiques entre ryad et
washington en épargnant le prince
héritier de toute sanction sur ce
dossier comme sur de nombreux autres
bailon poursuit en fait la diplomatie de
son prédécesseur anthony blinken a
d'ailleurs salué lors de cette réunion
virtuelle le succès est d accord
d'abraham qui je vous le rappelle ont
été signés sous la présidence de donald
trump il ya maintenant un an et que ce
soit sur les dossiers du nucléaire
iranien sur le dossier cubain ou encore
sur le dossier de l'afghanistan est bien
l administration de joe biden poursuit
la même politique d'abord été menée par
l'administration précédente et sur le
fond elle malgré les annonces d'un
retour au multilatéralisme promis par
joe biden le président des états unis
est en fait encore bien ancré dans
l'amérique a first si chère à donald
trump et la faire des sous marins
français en est l'illustration parfaite
après avoir beaucoup critiqué la
diplomatie de l'ancien président
républicain on peut dire que à la
différence d'à proches promise par joe
biden ne saute pas vraiment aux yeux
merci beaucoup avoue thomas bonnet en
direct depuis washington
et justement les états unis on l'a
entendu qu'avec l'aide de leurs fidèles
alliés le royaume uni ont raflé le
contrat du siècle à la france cette
semaine ce qui a provoqué l'ire de paris
une perte de 56 milliards d'euros pour
notre pays l'accord portait sur l'achat
de sous-marins un coup dans le dos a
déclaré jean yves le drian le ministre
des affaires étrangères en riposte paris
qui annule une soirée de gala prévue ce
soir à la résidence de l'ambassadeur de
france à washington
ce partenariat stratégique entre
l'australie les états unis et le royaume
uni sort donc du jeu la france et
s'inscrit dans un cadre de rivalités
entre chinois et américains
il met également en lumière
l'intensification de la course à
l'armement à l'armement on voit cela
avec sébastien hazard joe biden veut
faire front face à la chine c'était l'un
de ses objectifs majeurs de campagne et
après l'échec cuisant de la guerre en
afghanistan pékin reste le rival à
contenir la super puissance chinoise met
les bouchées doubles dans le
développement de son armement elle
alloue ainsi 252 milliards de dollars
par an à sa défense mais elle n'est pas
seule à faire un tel effort l'un d'eux
modernise son armement et les deux
corées multiplie les essais de missiles
balistiques
face à cette escalade l'australie se
sent vulnérable au point de chercher la
protection des états unis
pékin a vu au cours des derniers mois
que l'australie ne cédera pas et que les
menaces de représailles économiques et
les pressions ne fonctionneront tout
simplement pas je tiens également à
réitérer ce que j'ai déjà dit les états
unis ne laisseront pas l'australie seul
sur le terrain face à ces tactiques de
pression
c'est donc l'australie la nouvelle carte
que veut jouer washington dans la région
et le royaume uni vient de se joindre à
ses deux partenaires dans une alliance
indo pacifique prévue au cahier des
charges de cette entente
l'augmentation de la présence américaine
en australie la livraison de sous-marins
américain à propulsion nucléaire et la
multiplication d'exercices militaires
conjoints tout cela dans un seul but
tenir pékin à bonne distance
nous faisons juste le nécessaire pour
que les australiens soit en sécurité que
nos intérêts nationaux soient protégés
je veux dire la chine fait la même chose
ils font des investissements massifs
dans leurs capacités militaires y
compris dans cette région et l'australie
n'en fait pas un problème tous les pays
prennent des décisions conformes à leurs
intérêts nationaux nous croyons que
celle-ci renforcera la paix la stabilité
la sécurité de la région et c'est je
pense un point de vue largement partagé
sur les effets de cet arrangement nous
encourageons tous les pays de la région
à s'engager dans cette voie
selon les américains et les australiens
l'objectif reste tout d'abord le
maintien de la paix de son côté la chine
condamne fermement ce qu'elle perçoit
comme une frénésie d'armement elle qui a
augmenté son budget de la défense de 76
% en dix ans
l'exportation de la technologie
hautement sensible des sous marins
nucléaires par les états unis et le
royaume uni vers l'australie prouve une
fois de plus qu'ils utilisent les
exportations nucléaire comme un outil de
jeu géopolitique et applique deux poids
deux mesures ce qui est extrêmement
irresponsables reste à savoir quelle
sera la réponse chinoise sur le terrain
face à cette alliance
le pacte de sécurité conclu avec
l'australie le royaume-uni les
etats-unis le voient comme un gage de
paix et de stabilité dans la zone indo
pacifique alors faut-il y voir une aussi
une stratégie d'isolement de la france
par les états unis dans cette partie du
monde d'écouter les analyses du général
de brigade françois chossy et de
charles-henri gallois président du parti
génération frac site
discrètement derrière leurs alliés ou
son allié peu importe une alliance se
met en place pour nous évincer de l'inde
au pacifique dans lequel nous avons une
stratégie que nous avons d'ailleurs
développé avec l'australie on parle de
bach donne égale trump je l'avais dit
sur votre règle sur votre chaîne gay
quelques semaines j'avais dit la même
chose bayh dole trept même combat c'est
america first et on attend normalement
d'un gouvernement on va attendre un chef
de l'état qui est élu par les français
qui défendent les intérêts de la france
et des français et malheureusement on
voit que ce n'est pas le cas et il a la
volonté en fait de la france de
reprendre le contrôle d'un point de vue
la défense mais sur tous les sujets
c'est absolument vital si on veut que la
france soit un pays qui compte au 21ème
siècle est normalement c'est la vocation
de la france et on attend que ce soit le
cas
la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique de l'ouest sanctionne les
auteurs du putsch en guinée et appelle à
des élections d'ici six mois à la cedeao
qui a décidé hier de geler les avoirs
financiers des militaires une délégation
avec deux chefs d'état est sur place
pour à 1 à 12,7 jobard et auteur et
professeur de philosophie et chercheur
en éthique des relations internationales
la marge de manoeuvre de la cedeao en
guinée elle est réduite écouter pourquoi
la marge de manoeuvre de la cedeao me
paraît très faible d'abord il faut
rappeler que ces sanctions ne sont pas
une première 1 février 2018 en
guinée-bissau la cedeao a pris la même
mesure donc le fait qu'elle prennent
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la guinée
le même dispositif de sanctions
économiques devraient quand même incité
les gouvernements de la cedeao à plus de
réflexion mais je pense qu'il faudrait
appeler d'abord deux choses que la
cedeao et dans un accord de principe qui
vise à respecter sur le plan normatif la
façon dont elle fonctionne d'ailleurs en
sanctionnant ou un condamnant le coup
d'état mais on voit tout de suite que
cet accord de principe est en
contradiction totale avec les
aspirations légitimes des peuples ouest
africain en l'occurrence ici la guinée
qui aspirent à plus démocratie à la
justice de même on voit aussi que la
cedeao entretien dans une même logique
contradictoires la promotion des valeurs
démocratiques et la bonne gouvernance et
des pratiques autoritaires du pouvoir
dans cette contradiction aujourd'hui le
symptôme accentue la délégitimation du
cedeao au préalable à sion ouest
africaine
encore un moment fort et est douloureux
pour les victimes des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 pour leurs proches aussi
un quatrième jour de procès marqué par
la poursuite du visionnage des images de
cette soirée dramatique et puis la
diffusion aussi d'un enregistrement
sonore lors des attaques du bataclan
allez précision c'est avec notre
reporter katia technique depuis le
palais de justice à paris
ce ne sont que 22 secondes d'un audio
mais elles sont d'une violence inouïe
tout d'abord les notes de rock du groupe
eagles of death metal puis les rafales
très forte qui se succèdent la mitraille
ininterrompue la musique qui s'arrêtent
dollar cède quelques cris on imagine les
poux vente de ce moment inouï
l'enquêteur de la brigade criminelle
décrit avec pudeur et émotion des corps
enchevêtré le sang coagulé des bouts de
d'en projeter des scènes d'horreur qui
le plonge dans un état de sidération
il décrit des scènes de guerre le chaos
des écrous partout à la suite de
l'explosion des gilets
258 coups de feu rom mode rafale puis il
cite un enregistrement des terroristes
qui justifie leur geste en évoquant les
bombardements syrie des moments qui
continue à hanter les parties civiles on
les écoute on est tous tout on a tout
entendu
les grenades les tirs l'explosion les
jets ont en mémoire les espèces de
plafond qui tombait par ce devait être
les écrous voyez tout ça on entend des
puits dans un silence de mort c'est le
bruit x x et puis j'attends aussi la
parole les accusés évidemment qui qui
vont peut-être nous donner des indices
de comment ils en sont arrivés là en
fait parce que c'est vraiment ça qui est
insupportable de pas comprendre comment
des êtres humains arrivent à massacrer
d'autres êtres humains en voulant
dénoncer d'autres massacres jeu c'est
une logique qui est vraiment un qui
m'échappe c'est peut-être ce procès qui
va permettre d'avoir un petit peu plus
de compréhension ou mettre du sens parce
qu'ils ce qu'on a vécu qui pour
l'instant on n'a pas trop quoi à la fin
de la présentation de témoin a énoncé le
nom des victimes dans un panoramique du
bataclan refait avec le retour apprécié
où ils sont tombés le moment le plus dur
de grande tristesse de larmes philippe
dupeyron qui a perdu son fils au
bataclan en parle je pense que ça
contribue vraiment
forme de catharsis de quelque chose qui
se produit et qui participe malgré tout
à la progression dans notre parcours de
résilience
et
c'est aussi pour nous qui avons perdu
nos enfants
ou d'autres goûts des proches
une manière de vivre
ces derniers instants ses derniers
moments
[Musique]
et évidemment c'est très très douloureux
pour les parties civiles qui ont
souhaité assister au procès aujourd'hui
ces moments de clarté d'explication
parle enquêteurs de la brigade
criminelle sont difficiles mais
nécessaires pour passer un cap pour
s'extirper d'un marasme dans lequel les
attentats les ont plongés depuis six ans
pour laisser la fin de cet édifiant
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi on va se
retrouver en direct dans une trentaine
de minutes rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
tous
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
kicked off est-ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant poule et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont le dessin